banane
baleine
tu veux manger une banane
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tout le monde ça fait déjà
quelques semaines qu'on s'est pas parlé
j'étais sur Pékin Express ça c'est
terminé et retour aux affaires avec top
Chef le tournage qui a commencé à
quelques jours et le bistrot Top Chef
avec sa carte d'automne l'été bah il y a
eu 30 000 clients cet été en juillet
août et septembre et donc là on démarre
la carte d'automne que je l'espère aura
le même succès que la carte d'été on
verra bien et puis je vous enverrai
quelques vidéos du tournage de Top Chef
avec mes amis chefs qui sont en pleine
forme vous allez voir je vous embrasse
et à très bientôt
[Musique]
moi je suis un énorme fan de Drake
j'avais payé une table parce qu'il était
en club boîte de nuit j'avais payé une
table une fortune et en gros je passe
par la porte des robes derrière et tout
et je me retrouve que moi et lui c'est
pas genre il y a que moi Drake et ses
deux gars de sécu et je marche à côté de
lui et il est triste ce moment parce que
je fais Drake mais je suis là il est là
il y a que nous deux quoi il me regarde
pas mon frère
il me regarde pas même pas un regard
même pas un petit big up rien je fais et
moi et moi je lui dis ça